okay so far I found two dead ends and
two windows that lead to nowhere
whatever you got for me game I'm ready
to get the pants scared off of me
oddly enough I am wearing pants today I
don't know why I need to give you guys a
pants update every time I start
recording a game that's probably pretty
weird at this point but either way this
is someone else here I scribbled on this
note for no apparent reason why am I
here I seem to be in an abandoned
building maybe I'm scouting out a new
location for my nightmare factory but
other than that why would I be here why
the eternal question burning in
everyone's mind when they play these war
games why this seems like a bad idea
good let's do that again
yeah I expected it to not take that many
times there's a baby monitor here
strange why did I take the baby monitor
okay I'm out here I'm gonna go home now
I have done only Dodd what happened
what's going on what is going on why is
this happening to me
doors locked Oh God
it wasn't earlier it's bad no thank you
[Music]